ثم صرخ عليه شمعون ولاوي بالصيحة الخاطئة
سيجعل أختنا تهين شعبنا بهذه الطريقة
و نحن
سنصمت لن نصمت لقد فهموا الشرق
الشرق الأوسط هو شرف شعبكم
قبل كل شيء أعلاه
كل شيء وبعد ذلك مباشرة الآية
احضروا قمح الله على الجبال
محيطهم ما أخاف الناس من حولهم ولم يفعلوا ذلك
كيفية التقرب من شعب إسرائيل
أكثر مما فعله شمعون ولاوي
نابلس مع
حصلت إسرائيل على سمحات توراة
ضربة حصلت على ضربة
الأذى يمس شرف الناس
لقد تم خلاصنا
9208 دخلوا بيت حانون وفعلوا ما في بيت حانون
وهو ما فعله شمعون ولاوي في مدينة نابلس، ولكن ليس المهمة
المهمة انتهت، ولم تنته، ولا تزال لدينا غزة
شلومو يجعلها مثل بيت حانون غزة شلومو
يجب أن يبدو مثل منزل الطالب الذي يذاكر كثيرا الذي رأيته
اعرف السبب ليكون هناك خوف في جميع الأمم
حول المدن في جبال لبنان وجبال يهوذا
والسامرة وكل الأعداء الجالسين حولنا
ويعتقدون أنه من الممكن المساس بشرف شعب إسرائيل حينها
لقد انتهينا من الفصل الأول، ولكن
هذه البداية فقط، وسنعود بعون الله
نابلس وكل مدينة ترفع رأسها على شعب
إسرائيل سوف تبدو وكأنها الوطن
المهوس